адже скоро апарат зусиль на думку з
пустирі гачів дала чоловікові і весь москві
прорватися ізоляцію збоку заходу
обамою камерон знову вийду з путіним
діалог олланд після пари таких дарів
типу на вигляд літер будинку сквері просто
треба вірою на пружині всю венозну і за
ходом нікуди не знав і з розплата за раз
його на політику кремля в Україні
дивом але є шен api в руку продовжу у
санкції проти Росії
аша їх на віч розширив і на заході
поважають Москва кількою і м'ятою і в
зануренням мінських а ось про те реально
політика бентежить захисту засіки не матчу
ну спи вбити почати з кремлем про боротьбу з
тероризмом не матчі на край засікала
на політичному хіба занижувати лівого
конфлікту в сирії совина основну
причину та припливу біженців ми засікали
не в тому ще 50 про [ __ ] у нас сюди
конфлікту загнав 250 тисяч людей та 12
мільйонів стали біженцями
там наріжте розхитався мирний процес
посиланням очевидно щоб вразити його
зарубає і не можна ввести одну
встановити mac палець і правда експерти
не над оспорюються нато зараз більше
не Москви і заходу сторони вбити сумку
успішним , свічки мід мозком ми важливого
розуму blyad з москвою я поважаю обаму
пропустимо всю підлогу балка кулоном а а вся
він і до тазу зустрічі з путіним
all я навчу купи зближення буду чесним
вид з ним і принеси
успіх у скільки москва і захід мати
абсолютно різанини інтереси merchant
хостингу пасажирського
адже Москви на заході за словом вони
травневого експерта черга page за все
свої братію розрізання на люстрі
міжнародних конфліктів за краєм а ще
до України про нього дуже поважають росія
циклом вона в тому, щоб над сирійську
апараті
конфлікт в україні шоу тінь берліну
свою чару якира нішино польова навичку на
німецькі будинки у нас тому столітті добігають
киньте заперечувати порошок грудня
концерт бог йому засмічувати живем та сенатом
шукають здобутий сірків ногу при понині
кровопролиття на сході україни харчування
крему буде домовлятися у ж в рамках
іншого політичного процесу
замісив системи і напевно було б ще
менше шансів досяг 3 результатів його в
регулюванні конфлікту на сході України
зміцніють
таким крим на турботою з багата рази по 2
лайка slug вони матчі на ангела маркель
Проте раз на пішов плані для не матчі
на перебуваючи в регулюванні конфлікту
донбасі